[Music]
all right so let's go to the phones and
catch up with kelsey in seattle hey
kelsey what's going on
hi john thank you for taking my call
thank you for calling what's up and how
can i help
um
my my dad struggled with addiction most
of his life
and my little brother is following in
his footsteps
they slowly lost everything and were
living in a motel up until
my dad overdosed two weeks ago oh no i'm
so sorry kelsey
thanks
my brother texted us dad's dead and he
continues to do it yeah of course
we thought it would be rock bottom for
him
you know
um i'm heartbroken i'm angry with both
of them and i just don't have the hope
that i used to have
how do we deal with
how do we deal with the loss of our dad
when it was such a complicated
relationship
and how do we deal i mean how do we live
with the fear
you know that we're gonna lose my
brother too
i think first is to sit for a second
and it feels like you need to run and do
and and and
folks who love
addicts
live their lives waiting for this other
shoe to drop right
and
it's heartbreaking your dad was probably
also a pretty awesome guy too huh
yeah he um
he
he needed help that he didn't get yeah
he had a good heart but he did a lot of
things i mean he used with my little
brother
you know
i'm just
it's hard to
think about all the good things but then
there are some really bad things too yep
that's right
so
the the big elephant in the room here is
you just lost your dad
and you are
still in the middle of that trauma and
more
making this trauma more complex
is that you had a complicated
relationship with this guy
and so on top of the normal
heartbreak that would be two weeks out
from any of us losing our parent
is also you had seasons where you hated
this man right and you had seasons where
you despised him and he was yet he was
still your dad and you loved him and
then you had hope and then he just needs
to get through this season and oh my god
he's using with my brother
but maybe they're going to be good for
so right it's this this roller coaster
you've been living with and all that
complexity is on top of this grief right
yeah and the tendency we do we have in
these moments is to try to solve it all
right now and
the hardest thing i'm going to tell you
is you can't solve it today
yeah you just have to be heartbroken
that your dad's gone
and you didn't get that that
it didn't end like a disney movie right
right and y'all been waiting for that
ending for so long and it didn't happen
um
it doesn't surprise me it's not abnormal
it's it's equally heartbreaking
it doesn't surprise me that your brother
went right back to use him
because when you're using your covering
up you were
numbing over broken relationships and
the only one he has he feels like he has
left just left
right yeah and so to use that same
mechanism to cover up that same
challenge doesn't surprise me at all
it's heartbreaking and for those of us
who aren't addicts
withdraw when it comes to drugs i think
so many of us are addicts with different
things
it doesn't make any sense you're just
you think like you just saw someone you
love passed away what are you doing
that's just not how that addictive brain
solves math problems right
yeah so what's the last two weeks been
like
um
i mean my sister and i and my mom we try
to support each other the best that we
can
my brother's
not really answering phone calls and
can't i mean we can't be there for him
if he won't let us you know
have you all called the police on him
um
no he's i mean he's living in his car
and
i i don't know what they would do
you can do a welfare check
and sometimes
depending on what city you live in if
they have drug court or if they've got
if he doesn't have a long record
there are
communities assistance programs that
people can
have access to through the criminal
justice system
that's just one avenue that comes to the
top of my head or
finding the car knocking on it but i
also know you all been living with this
for a long long time
uh yeah how long's he been here he'll
text us here and there he has been since
she was a teenager
okay
my mom was in a pretty bad accident and
he
ended up taking pills from her
oh
man
it's been a long time he's been to rehab
a couple of times and
he got well for a while and
he's got two little kids and
they're gonna have to go through the
same stuff we did you
know lot
are the kids safe right now
yeah they're with their mom and
yeah she's got a good support system
okay
were y'all able to have a funeral for
your dad
no not really we got together and kind
of
did a small thing for him just us but
how come you didn't have a larger
funeral for him
i i don't know it's complicated okay
having some sort of ceremony to mark
this moment and to talk about
him being the fun dad the silly dad the
remember that time
and to talk through the complexity of
who he was this is the stuff that we're
not gonna miss
and also no addict i've ever met wants
to be an addict right
and
talk about
that he has peace finally right
um to be able to exchange those things
in some sort of ceremony with some sort
of people who cared about him even if
it's small is so important it becomes a
touchstone that you heal from
not marking this moment in some
important in some
definitive way it just leaves us
untethered for so so long right
at the end of the day you're in the
right place and that is heartbroken
sitting feeling like you're sitting in
the corner of your room covered up in
blankets and you just think what am i
gonna do next right yeah um
that's where you should be when your dad
dies even if he was a complex man that
made bad decisions you know what i mean
yeah
yeah
how's your mom doing
um they've been divorced for quite a
while um she basically went from dealing
with him and his addiction to my brother
basically
it's been a long road for her i know
it's hard for her too but
yeah so what does tomorrow look like for
you kelsey
um
well i've got four kids so i'm gonna
do what i can't you know yeah do they
know about their granddad
um they saw him a few times over the
years but
um
didn't have him around a lot sure
so they didn't really get to know the
good parts of him
which is
sad
do they know why mommy's sad right now
uh yeah my older ones do but
my little ones don't
yeah how old are you kids
uh
16 12 8 and 2
16 12 8 and 2.
so i think the 16 and the 8
and
the 12 year old i think they're old
enough to know about granddad and that
granddad was sick
and
i think it'd be a really neat family
thing
for you guys to write him a letter
and
it would be a neat way for them to get
to know their granddad and how much
um
there was some good stuff about them and
there was some not so great stuff about
them
and i think it's really important for
you to model for them what grieving
looks like
and it'd be cool for them to write them
a letter and say hey we never got to
know you and here's what you missed out
on because we're good kids
and we're sweet kids and we wish that
we'd gotten to know you but we didn't
um
but we're going to keep being good kids
and let them reiterate that does that
make sense
it it's it's not uncommon for grandkids
of addicts
to feel like it was somehow their fault
their grandparent didn't want
involvement in their life
yeah and so this is a healing moment for
everybody but there's something powerful
about writing that letter and if you
don't invite them into that conversation
i do think that's important for you
have you ever have you ever
sat down and written a letter to your
dad and let it all just out
i haven't
sounds like a good idea i've been
watching your show
[Applause]
it's um
it'll be one of the harder things you
ever do
and
the
it'll be important for you to read that
to somebody whether that's your husband
whether that's your mom and your sister
um it could be a neat moment that you
and your and your mom and your sister
all write letters to him and then you
all get together and read them too out
loud there's just something about grief
being witnessed that is healing and i
wish i knew the math on it i wish i knew
the exact
um biochemical responses in the body i
don't i know that it's healing
when people witness grief together
and there would be laughter and tears
and memories and everyone could breathe
you know what i mean
and that's how you can also get some
clarity with your brother have you ever
written your brother a letter
i haven't we've texted with him but
you know yeah there's something about
that and that may be a conversation for
you and your mom and your sister or
maybe it's just two sisters right letter
but a actual
tangible letter that you can get in his
hands that he can go back to over and
over and you tell me you love him
and um you're there for him
and you miss him and you don't want him
to turn out like dad
and
you will
be looking for him
when he's ready to get clean right and
you'll be can't wait till he makes that
choice
but i think that's again it's one of
those neat moments that sisters can
reach out brothers can reach out there's
something powerful both for the author
and the receiver of that letter
but that's what i would do right now in
your grief and here's the thing you may
write three or four letters to your dad
over the next couple of months
one that just says i miss you i can't
believe you died one that's is rage i
cannot believe this was my childhood i
can't believe you used drugs with my
little brother and now look at him
i can't believe i can't believe i can't
believe you didn't know your grandkids
they're awesome
and you missed out
and there may be a heartbroken daughter
to dad letter just says man i miss you
i miss you so much
and man i held out hope for you and it
didn't come true but i held out hope for
you i want you to know that right
there's something about getting that out
and writing it down letting there be
some distance between you and those
thoughts and you and that pain and being
able to sit with it
and again find somebody whether it's
your husband your wife uh
your husband your wife your your husband
your sisters your mom who you can read
those letters to and vice versa
have your husband join you he can write
your data letter too but
man i'm so sorry
losing a parent is heavy
and losing a parent with the complexity
of a drug addict is
it's even more messy
and then missing your brother on top of
all that is even messy on top of messi
so when those things happen when our
lives spin out on us like that writing
stuff down and getting away from it is
so helpful not away from the feelings no
not running no
but being able to
to create some space between
us and that weight that blanket that's
just laying on us not letting us breathe
and it's just gonna take some time to
heal and it's gonna take some months
that are gonna turn into years and
you're in it now
i'm so so sorry for your loss
stick by those that you love
so sorry kelsey